[Music]
now i'm going to give you a very
whistle-stop
tour of the limits of knowledge this is
an open-top bus store
bus tour the like of which you've never
seen
first um i want to introduce you to um
i think uh posterity will
view as the greatest
philosopher of the 20th century and that
is i refer of course to
donald rumsfeld the former um
defense secretary of the united states
who
probably trying to
uh to evade some direct questioning said
there were three kinds of
knowledge there are the known knowns
there are the things that we know that
we know
and then there are the known unknowns
they're the things
that we know that we don't know in other
words we do know that there are some
things that we don't know
and finally there are also the unknown
unknowns and these are the things
these are the facts that we don't know
that we don't know
but there's knowledge out there that we
have no idea
that it exists now we all know
or think we know the things that we know
we know no
first of all here's an example we all
know
or think we know that the sun is going
to come up in the morning
every day uh and we've known this since
antiquity
um so we can reliably
state because we've seen it every day
ourselves
that uh the sun will come up in the
morning now um
there probably was a time when one aztec
would say to the other we'd have to do
the human sacrifice now but
um all the sun won't come up tomorrow
and the other one says yeah but we know
the sun will always come up tomorrow and
the other one said
care to care to miss it and see ah i see
the point
but we have since then sent
satellites into space and we know
something about the structure of the
local universe
we know that the earth revolves around
the sun and that
it's as sure as shaw can be but the sun
will come up in the morning so that's
one thing that we know we know
although you're probably beginning to
detect that even with the things that we
know that we know
there are some fuzziness there's some
little boojums at the edges
another one we think we know we know is
basic arithmetic
one plus one is two two plus two equals
four
and all the operations of uh basic mass
um so these were always the case when i
was at school and when your children
were at school and those of you who are
doing homeschooling will
will will know to a nauseating degree
but this is something we know we know
however
even in the basics of the arithmetic
they're little boojums at the edges
things that are
unknown things that are strain the
limits of knowledge
back in the early 20th century the
philosopher bertrand russell
and his friend uh alfred north whitehead
wanted were fascinated by the philosophy
of
numbers why are numbers what are numbers
what is their property
and they thought that mathematics was on
a very uncertain footing
and wanted to pin it down they wanted to
find the
substructure of mathematics reducing
everything to logic
and in their huge book called principle
mathematica
it took them you know loads and loads of
pages and thoughts just to get to prove
that one plus one was two
what they were trying to do was find
that there's a logical structure
under arithmetic
now this was fine until the 1930s when a
fellow called kurt
gerdel came along and he said
that um there are in any
mathematical system that is
complete in other words it can it
connects
it can express any
uh any theorem any view that you want
there will be some statements that you
know are true
but you can't prove it in other words
there are undecidable propositions
so um that goes to show that um
even in but basic maths there are things
that you can't
know that you know i'll move on
now uh time was not very long ago that
everyone thought that the earth was
created in 4004 bc
on one day of october at tea time this
was uh
worked out by a chap called archbishop
of usher he was
he was the archbishop of omar in ireland
um but since then we've found uh using a
lot of scientific methods and
geology and stratigraphy that the earth
is very very old and there is a fossil
record
um the earth is extremely old so this
has been shown to be the case by
multiple intersecting corroborating
lines of evidence so these are things
that we know that we know and there are
lots of things i'm sure you can think of
like
that however so we do have
some idea of some of the things we know
we don't know
now this is where science works science
is all about
trying to investigate the things that we
know that we don't know
and here are a few of those one is
we know that we don't know that there is
something called dark matter
well we know that we know that there is
something called dark matter but we
don't know what it's made of
uh we know looking at the motions of
stars and galaxies that they do things
that are um incompatible
uh with the law of gravity provided that
all the matter we see is all we can
see in other words there's a lot more
matter we can't see it's called dark
matter and we don't know what it's made
of
another thing that we know we don't know
is
how many species there are on the planet
now i was in a debate yesterday about
extinction
and one of the problems about extinction
is we don't know how many species there
are on the planet
people have tried to count this in
various ways by digging up soil and
sampling the microbes
or rattling trees and seeing how many
things fall out and extrapolating it
and you know estimates have varied from
a million species to hundreds of
millions of species
we know that there are a lot of species
but we don't know how
many there are so that's something one
of the things we know that we don't know
another thing that we know that we don't
know is whether there is any
life in the universe apart from uh
on the earth a subsidiary is if there's
in any intelligent life
in the universe now my son tells me that
there is no intelligent life on earth
because he's just waiting for the lizard
people
to come down and claim him for their own
and my son the same fellow when much
younger drew a picture which i wish i
could show you
um of a very fed up looking garlic
and the caption i'm fed up of
exterminating
i want to be a celebrity chef so
we don't know if there are any daleks
let alone those who have
fed up of exterminating and want to bake
cakes instead
this is something we know that we don't
know and i'm sure you can think of a lot
of things
in fact the whole of scientific inquiry
is based on this
people look at the world or their
experimental system
and ask questions of it they can do this
either by collecting lots of data in an
undirected way and then seeing if any
patterns emerge
or they can ask a question of it a
hypothesis
and then collecting the data to test the
hypothesis
now these are called inductive reasoning
and deductive reasoning and i can never
remember which is which and it doesn't
matter because they're not mutually
exclusive
but this is what scientists do and this
concerns me greatly
because in my day job i am a
i am a senior editor of the science
journal nature
and in nature we like to um
entertain as it were the most cutting
edge
research right at the edge of science
right at the edge of knowledge where
people are really
looking into the gloom and
um finding new things that nobody
knew before so what about the things we
don't know
we don't know now before we start
we have to realize that there are things
we don't know we don't know
and i say that because there is a strand
of thought among some scientists
that knowledge and ignorance are a
zero-sum game
and the more things we know uh the less
ignorance
there is when in other words we're
shining an ever
brighter light into an ever shrinking
puddle of ignorance
oh contraire i i think that the more we
find out the more
we realize that how much we don't know
our knowledge our ignorance increases
disproportionately
to the amount of knowledge so for
example
if you're struggling up some hill and
you see the horizon and you think that's
the top of the hill
and you think goodness me i know that's
the horizon it's the top of the hill but
when you get there you find that there's
even more hills to climb
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas